Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. There's been a bunch of Daredevil
Born Again
announcements and reveals recently
so we'll break it all down Charlie Cox Vincent
D'Onofrio some of the biggest characters from
the original Netflix Defender series coming back
so if you're pretty new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'll be doing
videos for the series as they continue to film
through pretty much all of next year because
there's going to be 18 episodes they're going
to be filming for a long time we will get a lot
of teasers from the set and they're filming the
series in New York which means we have a much
better chance of actually getting footage here's
Charlie Cox talking about the series hey my name's
Charlie Cox I play Matt Murdock AKA Daredevil in
Marvel's daredevil on Disney plus Marvel's
Daredevil is a crime drama which tells the
story of a blind lawyer by day Superhero by night
who attempts to help people using both the law and
vigilantism and yet struggles with the morality of
his actions for me Daredevil represents the idea
that sometimes small day-to-day acts of kindness
or help can make big differences and instigate
large change over time people love superheroes
and what makes Daredevil special is that this
character has to struggle and sacrifice a lot in
order to be impactful and I think viewers relate
to how difficult making the right decisions in
life can be sometimes I'm very grateful to have
been given the opportunity to play a character
who means so much to people who have perhaps
struggled in their life in some way or felt held
back by something in their life and to be able
to do it over the course of three seasons and in
the Defenders to be given the opportunity to do
it for so long was a great honor you can watch
Marvel's Daredevil now streaming on Disney Plus
you've also probably seen the footage of him
getting back into Daredevil shape training for the
series his explanation of the series there is a
good example of why Daredevil is such an important
character going forward in the MCU right now I see
him as being a key member of The Avengers he's the
most important ground level character if you don't
include Spider-Man technically Spider-Man is kind
of a ground level hero but the way they treated
him in the MCU is more of like a big Avengers
level character Spider-Man is probably one of
the most popular characters in the history of
comics period next to Batman and Superman so
even though he was originally created to be a
ground level hero just like this regular teenager
trying to deal with all this crazy stuff going on
around him and these powers that he gotten in the
MCU the last several years they've used them in a
much bigger Avengers level way but at his core
being a ground level hero is one of the reasons
why Spider-Man 4 will be more of a ground level
type of movie why they took him back to ground
so to speak at the end of Spider-Man no way home
and that's what brings him back into the periphery
of a character like Daredevil who has up to
this point so far in the movies the TV shows
then their preeminent ground level character
both of them are probably the most important
point of view characters that Marvel has access
to going forward in the MCU because both of the
characters were around for everything during
Marvel Phase 1 like everything that's happened
in the MCU so far they were both around for
Avengers Infinity War Avengers end game they
witnessed everything that happened even though
there's a lot of questions about what was going
on with Daredevil during the five-year time
Jump because of what they did in Hawkeye we
know more about what happened with Kingpin
during the five-year time Jump that we know
about Daredevil but both Daredevil and Spider-Man
will be here for everything that's coming up so
that's why they're so important for Marvel just
in general just as characters my client has
nothing to do with the missing technology he's
a law-abiding citizen he has nothing to hide
that's right the only big difference recently
is because Kevin feige unified Marvel television
with the movie production in a bigger way the
narrative crosses over with the TV shows and
the movies in a much clearer way which is how
you get your Daredevil and Spider-Man team-ups
like actually seeing them together on screen which
according to Charlie Cox was something that they
very literally could not do before like he said
it was not in the cars when they were making the
original Daredevil Netflix series and there are
big plans for Daredevil in the future of Marvel
movies not just the Daredevil Born Again series
and the TV stuff I'll talk about that later in
the video the big news you probably saw recently
is that they just cast Michael Gandolfini James
gandolfini's son and I believe he's going to be
playing a version of young Kingpin like young
Wilson Fisk in his 20s that will be during his
early rise to power like he hadn't become the
Kingpin of crime yet that didn't happen till
the events of Daredevil season 1 when he's in
his 40s the way they explained the Kingpin name
during Daredevil Netflix was that at the time he
become a Power player with the New York crime
families but hadn't taken control of all crime
families yet and the other big players in the
the New York crime scene would use the kingpid
name in a derogatory way like it was a slur that
people would use to describe him because the whole
idea is that you weren't supposed to say his
name if you don't remember like that was a big
thing during Daredevil season one no no we can't
mention his name and don't use the Kingpin name
either so Wilson Fisk actually really hated the
Kingpin name he didn't really become true comic
book Kingpin until closer to Daredevil season 3
which is funny because like the whole brand new
series is called Daredevil born again on Disney
plus the Daredevil born again story from the
comics was the one that they adapted for Daredevil
Netflix season 3. that doesn't mean the new series
is going to be a complete reboot it just means
that they really like the title Daredevil born
again and the relevance to what's happening
with the character in real life like he is
born again now in the MCU in a much clearer way
even though the way that Charlie Cox and visit
dinofro talk about it most of what happened during
Daredevil Netflix the Netflix Defender series is
still Canon but they'll retune a couple things
there'll be some reimagining of a few things
like you probably heard a bunch of news recently
about what's going on with foggy no Nelson Karen
Page they will come back for the Daredevil Born
Again series even though the actors have said no
we haven't been contacted yet we don't know but
we'd love to come back if you remember the last
couple of years Charlie Cox said the exact same
thing about Daredevil coming back in Spider-Man
no way home like oh I don't know anything about
that I don't know what you're talking about but
I would love to come back that'd be amazing
politic Andrew Garfield on us speak of Amazing
Spider-Man Charlie Cox also made another Peter
number three joke recently that you probably saw
on social media it was actually pretty solid as
well as starring in one of the highest grossing
movies ever where he solidified his legacy
as the third greatest Spider-Man of all time
the third greatest Spider-Man of all time Peter
number three coming in for the win in truth
they're actually really good friends that's why
he could make that joke it would be cool if they
actually meet on screen as Peter number three The
Amazing Spider-Man character and Daredevil during
Avengers 6 Secret Wars when you talk about the
other Netflix Defenders characters coming back
I think the idea is that eventually most of them
will all come back the only one I know for sure
right now is supposed to be Kristen Ritter coming
back as Jessica Jones we're supposed to get a
teaser for that during the echo series because
there's going to be a bunch of Daredevil and a
bunch of Kingpin during that next year those
episodes will happen next year Daredevil Born
Again episodes won't come till early 2024.
you've also probably seen people posting
about Jenny Ortega showing up as a version of
white tiger on the series if you haven't been
watching it she's been on the Wednesday Netflix
series recently but she's already been in the
MCU the funny thing about this is one of those
situations where you have actors showing up as
multiple characters in completely different movies
and completely different roles several years ago
Jenny Ortega played the daughter of Miguel ferreir
players vice president Rodriguez in Iron Man 3.
forgot she'd already been in the MCU until I
read the news about it but that's one of the
reasons why it's easy for actors to come back and
play completely different characters because the
character that they originally played was either
like a one-off or just somebody really small in
the background that you tend to forget white
Tiger's real name was Angela Del Toro she was
an FBI agent that was tasked with investigating
Daredevil she was transformed into white tiger
when she got this powerful amulet that was passed
down by her uncle and Daredevil eventually took
her under his wing and taught her how to be a hero
there'll be 18 episodes of season one so there's
like a bunch of characters that they're going
to introduce they will do multiple Seasons like
they're doing Loki season two they'll probably be
a Loki season 3 eventually but the way that Marvel
plots things out on Disney plus the way their
Productions work is usually there's like a year
break between Seasons so don't be surprised if we
get 18 episodes of Daredevil Born Again season one
and then a couple years later we get season two
with a bunch more episodes it's kind of a bummer
but it is the trade-off for getting so many new
Marvel series and movies every year once Marvel
figures out a lot of its production issues the
constellation going forward is that when there
is a big break between really popular Seasons
the character will usually show up in some movie
between those Seasons so it's not like you see
Daredevil and then you have to wait another like
five years to see him again I see him as being a
key member of The Avengers Charlie Cox did talk
about Daredevil being on an Avengers team being in
the Avengers movies in the future like I said the
russos actually wanted to include him during
Avengers Infinity War Avengers end game some
of the other Netflix characters but there were
already like so many things going on there and
there was so much politics behind the scenes now
that Kevin feige has taken control of all the TV
Productions and all the movie productions is way
easier for them to figure that stuff out Vincent
D'Onofrio did talk about Daredevil and Kingpin
showing up in Spider-Man movies in the future
I believe those will probably be the next places
that we'll see the characters in the movies based
on all Marvel and Sony's plans right now I believe
they want to get Spider-Man 4 out by July 2024 but
that could wind up being July 2025 if things take
a little bit longer but like I said Daredevil Born
Again episodes in 2024 that would mean you don't
have to wait till 2025 to see Daredevil again
after that I don't know that there are plans for
Daredevil to show up in any of the other Marvel
movies aside from Avengers 6 Secret Wars he could
always show up during Avengers 5 King Dynasty
but I think Secret Wars is like the next big plan
thing after the upcoming Spider-Man movies I'll do
more videos about Daredevil born again as we get
more announcements more teasers from the set like
I said they'll be filming for pretty much all of
next year so we're going to get a lot of footage
from the set if you have any questions about the
series or the future of the Daredevil character
just post them in the comments below everyone
click here for my brand new Adam Warlock Guardians
of the Galaxy video and click here for my full
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!